Brady and Neal thought it might be fun
to try and add a piece of metallic
lithium to 7up the reason for this is
that long ago 7up used to contain
lithium salts so they thought it'd be a
bit of a joke they bought a bottle of
7up this is not product placement and
they poured some into a beaker and
dropped in a piece of lithium
of course it bubbled partly the co2
coming out of the fizzy drink partly the
hydrogen from the reaction
but what was surprising is that the
solution started to go pale green and
then it went a reddish brown color and
by the time I went into the lab looked
like beer the obvious first stage is
little metal reacts with water to form
lithium hydroxide which is an alkali
that alkali might react further with the
other components of 7up and if you read
about it it contains sugar natural lemon
and lime flavor whatever that is and it
also contains no caffeine
so there's no caffeine chemistry here
the first question is how would the
acidity or alkalinity of the solution
change so we measured the pH of fresh
7up which turned out to be slightly
acidic as you might expect if you
dissolve carbon dioxide into water and
we measured the acidity of the 7up plus
lithium and again as expected it was
pretty alkaline so a possible
explanation for the color is that it was
produced by the alkaline conditions and
the alkali was causing a reaction of the
other components of the 7up lithium
salts are completely colorless they're
all white just like table salt so the
question is why is it going colored and
brown I suggested an experiment if it
was the alkaline we should get a similar
effect if we put sodium hydroxide which
is a strong alkali into some 7up to
begin with nothing happened neil and
bragged he got quite excited that
professors wrong you see one up for them
but then as we watched the pellets of
sodium hydroxide started developing a
red color almost as if they were
bleeding it was really rather beautiful
and the color began to develop it was
reacting slowly
much more slowly than the reaction that
we saw with lithium we noticed that the
lithium hydroxide one the one that we
put lit in metal
the solution was quite hot and Neil
dipped a thermocouple into the sodium
hydroxide plus 7up and found that that
surface was nearly at room temperature
but down where the color was developing
it was quite warm nearly 50 degrees you
might say why wasn't it convecting well
of course the concentrated solution of
sodium hydroxide is very dense so you
get less convection that you would
normally in water
we added some more sodium hydroxide and
the color developed and so the reason
why temperature is important is because
most reactions of organic compounds like
the sugars in the 7up double their rate
for each 10 degrees centigrade that you
go up so if you go from room temperature
20 to 30 to 40 to 50 the rate will go up
about eight times doubling each time so
that would explain the difference by
this time the lithium beaker was looking
pretty dark and you can really tell what
color it was so I suggested that we
diluted a bit into water so we've got a
beaker of water not 7up just pure water
and added a little bit of the solution
and it looked as a yellowy brown color
suddenly I thought perhaps whatever
colored compound we'd made might be an
indicator you know that changes color if
you go from acid to alkali so Neel had
some concentrated sulfuric acid which a
bit fierce so he diluted that and we
poured in the sulfuric acid and much to
my pleasure it went completely colorless
so whatever we made change color
depending on the pH depending on the
acidity
then I wondered what would happen if we
added more alkaline and when we ended
more alkali it changed back to color now
of course there are two explanations the
first one is we may have created an
indicator out of 7up the other
explanation is that whatever was
reacting in the 7up there was still some
in the water and that reacted with the
alkali again so you can't be absolutely
sure what happened in the final stage
but if they seem to behave like an
indicator when we put in more alkaline
it could be that that compound changed
back or it could be that there was still
sugar in the solution and we just made
more of the starting compound and you
can't really tell the difference without
more careful experiments look like an
artwork and I persuaded Brady and Neil
that we should watch it melting